This is a story about
an incredible primate.
Highly sociable,
extremely affectionate,
and very vocal.
(squeak)
The golden snub-nosed monkey.
Its home: China's
remote mountain forests.
China is a realm
of diverse landscapes,
full of rare and
surprising creatures.
For the first time,
we'll uncover their
remarkable untold stories
in The Hidden Kingdoms
of China.
♪ ♪
A newborn golden
snub-nosed monkey.
She's just a few hours old
and entirely dependent
on her mother.
♪ ♪
In the year ahead she'll be
at her most vulnerable
and will face many challenges.
She'll need intelligence,
strength,
and most of all,
her family's care and love,
if she's to survive in China's
mountain forest kingdom.
♪ ♪
The endangered golden
snub-nosed monkey lives only
in the high mountain forests
of central China.
♪ ♪
Up to 13,000 feet
above sea level.
♪ ♪
(cry)
Our baby girl's troop lives
in the world's largest
high altitude forest,
where there are
more tree species
than in any other
deciduous forest on Earth.
(birds chirping)
It's spring.
And the monkeys
are in high spirits.
♪ ♪
The troop has five families.
Each with one male,
several females,
and their young.
(squeak)
Males that aren't
part of the family
live in the troop's
bachelor gang.
♪ ♪
They're a boisterous bunch,
but right now, they're not
the center of attention.
That honor belongs
to our baby girl.
She's the first born
this spring,
and the females in the family
will do anything
to get a cuddle.
(squeaking)
This auntie is first in line.
But not for long.
(squeaking)
With only one baby
to go around,
competition is fierce.
(squeaking)
♪ ♪
When it all gets
a bit too much,
it's mom to the rescue.
♪ ♪
(squeak)
The monkeys' attention soon
turns to their tummies.
In spring they spend
a quarter of daylight hours
eating fresh new leaves.
Their favorite food and
an important source of protein.
As temperatures rise,
trees higher up the mountain
spring to life.
And the monkeys
follow the feast.
(cry)
Crystal clear streams
run through
these high forest valleys.
The surrounding trees
filter the rain,
and their shade keeps
the water cool,
helping to maintain healthy
levels of dissolved oxygen.
These pristine streams
are a lifeline.
And not just for the monkeys.
♪ ♪
One of China's strangest
creatures lives here.
♪ ♪
The Chinese giant salamander
has hardly changed
since the Jurassic period
over 170 million years ago.
♪ ♪
Growing up to 6 feet long,
it's the largest amphibian
in the world.
This female has tiny eyes
and poor vision,
relying instead on smell, touch
and sensing vibrations
to get around.
She spends most of her life
underwater,
absorbing oxygen
through her skin.
Folds increase the surface
area, maximizing the process.
Although revered for centuries
in China,
illegal hunting and
habitat destruction has left
these creatures critically
endangered in the wild.
For the few who remain,
remote forest streams like this
are a vital refuge.
♪ ♪
Our baby girl is now
three weeks old
and exploring her forest home.
She soon discovers that she
shares it with other creatures.
♪ ♪
But it's the family's
playful youngsters
that really catch her eye.
♪ ♪
A year or two older than her,
their lives seem like
one endless play session.
And she's eager to try out some
of the skills they've mastered.
♪ ♪
Hanging from one arm
is best tried
close to the ground
to begin with.
(whimper)
♪ ♪
Walking along a branch
looks easy,
but for our baby
it takes concentration...
bravery...
and brain power.
She's figuring out
how to turn around
and get back to mom.
A moment of comfort...
...before the next adventure.
Babies learn very quickly.
♪ ♪
And soon, she's climbing trees.
By following her instincts
and imitating others,
she's grasping
essential monkey skills.
♪ ♪
Spring is when all
the new babies are born.
It offers them
the best chance of survival,
as they'll have the warmer
months to grow strong.
But in this high mountain
forest, nothing is guaranteed.
Spring weather can change
in an instant.
A sudden drop in temperature
threatens all
the troop's babies.
In China's
high mountain forests,
spring rain brings
a sudden drop in temperature.
Our baby girl doesn't yet
have a full coat
to protect her from
the cold and wet.
Alone in the treetops, she's
vulnerable to hypothermia.
♪ ♪
(squeaking)
Her mom and family step in
to keep her warm and dry.
But as the weather worsens,
rain turns to snow.
♪ ♪
Disaster strikes the family.
(crying)
♪ ♪
A mother cradles the lifeless
body of her newborn baby.
♪ ♪
Her maternal instinct
is so strong,
she cares for her infant
as though it's still alive.
♪ ♪
Family members try
to comfort her.
♪ ♪
But she seeks solitude.
These monkeys seem
to understand death,
and this mother isn't
ready to let go.
♪ ♪
The sunshine returns,
and life flourishes once more
in the mountain forests.
In time, spring
turns to summer.
♪ ♪
Trees are in full bloom,
and food is plentiful.
This area has more than
4,000 plant species,
making these forests
among the most biologically
diverse on Earth.
With food in such easy reach,
there's plenty of time
for other activities,
such as grooming.
An all-important part
of monkey society.
It keeps skin and fur clean.
But more importantly, builds
and cements relationships.
(squeak)
And it's just so relaxing.
Naptime soon follows.
♪ ♪
Our baby girl
doesn't doze for long.
♪ ♪
(squeaking)
At three months old,
with stronger muscles
and hand-eye coordination,
she's coming on
leaps and bounds.
♪ ♪
And she's taking a big step
in her social development.
Playing with other babies.
♪ ♪
(squeaking)
But at this age,
she's soon distracted
and wanders off exploring.
As the adults doze
in the afternoon sun,
a cold-blooded killer
is waking up.
♪ ♪
And our baby girl has
caught his attention.
A king rat snake is heading
towards our baby girl.
This constrictor
eats any creature
it can wrap itself around.
♪ ♪
(yip)
The alarm is raised.
(squeaking, yipping)
Many pairs of eyes help
keep the monkeys safe.
(squeaking)
The troop moves on.
In this complex society,
these intelligent monkeys use
many different vocalizations.
(squeaking, yipping)
As the families and
bachelor gang travel together,
contact calls keep them
all in touch.
(squeaking)
Individuals have their own
unique signature calls.
(whine)
Particularly useful
in dense vegetation
when they can't see
each other well.
(squeaking)
They have lots to talk about
in their ever-changing world.
(squeaking)
And the seasons are
turning once more.
♪ ♪
Fall is arriving.
One of the most spectacular
times of year.
♪ ♪
(squeaking)
At six months old,
our baby girl still
depends on mom's milk.
But she's also developing
a taste for new things.
She takes her first bites
of solid food.
Tries her hand at grooming.
And she spends more time
than ever playing.
♪ ♪
Ten times more than
she did in summer.
(squeak)
♪ ♪
Playing is fun,
but it's important, too.
It keeps the monkeys
fit and strong,
enhances their social skills,
and sharpens their brains.
♪ ♪
As long as they get
the landing right.
In Chinese folklore,
monkeys represent
rebellion and mischief.
(screeching)
One group that lives up
to that reputation
is the troop's bachelor gang.
These young males were evicted
from their families
before they turned three.
(wee)
(squeaking)
They wrestle endlessly,
preparing for the day
they'll fight to try
to win their own family.
One of the older bachelors
has reached that point.
♪ ♪
Aged seven,
the warts on his lips
show that he's sexually mature.
Apparently, these warts
are attractive to females.
He'll win the right to mate,
if he can take over a family.
(squeaking)
♪ ♪
He's going to try to overthrow
our baby girl's dad.
♪ ♪
(squeak)
Dad and his family
are under threat.
Males who take over have
been known to kill babies,
so that they can sire
their own offspring.
Our baby girl could be
in grave danger.
(shrieking)
A challenger is battling
our baby girl's dad,
hoping to take over his family.
♪ ♪
If he wins, he could kill her.
(shrieking)
Dad's an experienced fighter,
but not as young and strong
as he used to be.
What he does have
is the support of his females.
(shrieking)
♪ ♪
The challenger is sent packing.
Dad returns to our baby girl's
mom for comfort.
It's thanks to the females
that he's kept his position
in the family...
...including his mating rights.
Fall is the breeding season,
and the female who lost
her baby in spring
is ready to mate again.
To win the male's affections
she showers him with attention.
Female golden snub-nosed
monkeys use grooming
as currency, hoping
to exchange it for sex.
♪ ♪
And she seems to be finding
all the right spots.
♪ ♪
(squeak)
They'll mate several times.
But only time will tell if
she'll give birth next spring.
♪ ♪
With fall progressing
in China's forests,
trees shed their leaves.
♪ ♪
A way to save energy during
the cold months ahead.
♪ ♪
With less on offer,
the monkeys eat bamboo leaves
and pine needles.
All the forest's creatures
get ready for winter.
♪ ♪
This remote
high altitude refuge
is home to over
90 mammal species.
But most are secretive
and seldom seen.
♪ ♪
Yellow-throated marten
search the forest floor
for fallen fruit and seeds.
♪ ♪
The forest provides
this vital food source,
and the martens
return the favor.
Traveling far and wide,
they spread seeds
through their droppings.
♪ ♪
And seeds disperse
in more than one way.
♪ ♪
Some attach to
the monkeys' coats.
♪ ♪
In fall, the monkeys travel
up to two miles each day,
spreading the seeds as they go.
♪ ♪
The forest's plants and animals
depend on one another
for survival.
♪ ♪
Our baby girl is now
nine months old,
and with a thicker coat
she's ready for
the harshest time of year.
♪ ♪
She seems fascinated by
the first snows of winter...
♪ ♪
...and explores
her frosty world.
What she doesn't yet know
is that four months of snow
lies ahead.
To get through it, she'll need
to master a new skill,
unique to these monkeys.
♪ ♪
As winter temperatures plummet,
our baby girl seeks comfort
and warmth with her mom.
♪ ♪
They can't escape the cold.
In fact, these monkeys tolerate
the coldest
average temperatures
of any non-human primate
on the planet.
♪ ♪
Their dense golden coats
thicken up in winter...
...covering their
hands and feet.
And those strange snub noses
are less exposed to frostbite.
They also have another
remarkable adaptation.
♪ ♪
They're the only monkeys
in the world
known to travel
on two legs in snow.
♪ ♪
It keeps their hands
off the cold ground.
♪ ♪
And helps them travel faster,
reducing the time they spend
in contact with the icy snow.
♪ ♪
Our baby girl reaches
another milestone...
...as she gets the hang
of this new skill.
♪ ♪
This unique behavior
could be the source
of an ancient Chinese legend.
These forests are said
to be home to wild men.
Mysterious ape-like figures
with red hair,
who walk upright
through the trees.
♪ ♪
Sounds a lot like
the golden snub-nosed monkey.
Or maybe there really are
unknown and mysterious wild men
roaming these forests.
(bird caws)
To escape the freezing
temperatures
in China's forests,
some creatures hibernate,
and others migrate.
For those who stick around,
having a strategy is vital.
This little guy is a sable.
Rarely seen or filmed,
he's a smaller cousin of
the yellow-throated marten.
Today he's out hunting.
Using his keen sense of smell
and sharp hearing
to search for small prey.
Large snowshoe-like feet
help him travel lightly
on top of the deep snow.
Winter is the hardest time
to find food,
but he's got that covered.
♪ ♪
When times were good,
he stockpiled food underground.
This survival strategy
is a lifesaver.
♪ ♪
To generate enough body heat
to stay alive,
the monkeys now need
more calories
than at any other time of year.
Carbohydrate-rich bark
and lichens
become their main
source of food.
Diverse gut organisms and
a multi-chambered stomach
help them digest
this tough diet.
♪ ♪
As winter reaches
its coldest point,
the temperature plunges
to -4 degrees Fahrenheit.
(wind blowing)
The monkeys could
freeze to death.
They need another way
to stay warm.
In the depths of winter,
our baby girl
and family struggle
in subzero temperatures.
♪ ♪
But luckily, they have
another way to keep warm.
♪ ♪
Sharing body heat.
These affectionate monkeys
huddle all year round,
but they do it
much more in winter.
Their lives depend on being
surrounded by family...
...or fellow bachelors.
♪ ♪
(squeak)
Our baby girl hides out
in the warmest spot...
♪ ♪
...until it's safe
to venture out again.
(chirping)
(squeak)
(birds chirping)
♪ ♪
Winter's long silence
is finally broken.
♪ ♪
It's a time of transformation
and celebration.
♪ ♪
The monkeys have
lost body weight,
but their favorite food
is growing again.
♪ ♪
Our baby girl is
now a year old.
As grown up as she's become,
she still returns frequently
to mom for milk and comfort.
She won't be fully weaned
for another year,
when her mom gives birth again.
And even then,
they'll likely stay close
for a few more years.
The cycle of life
keeps turning.
And the family
continues to grow.
The female that lost her baby
last spring has a new arrival.
Already two weeks old,
he's healthy and strong.
♪ ♪
Our yearling girl is eager
to introduce herself
to her new little cousin.
♪ ♪
No longer the baby,
she knows that in the future
he'll be a playmate and
someone she can help care for.
♪ ♪
One day she'll likely
become a mother herself,
and continue the long line of
these extraordinary monkeys
living in China's
hidden forest kingdom.
Captioned by
Side Door Media Services